hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational we
are continuing the match for Bianca
Corwin and versus Maxine Marshall a
graph and this is Game three Game one as
you know was won by fabbi Game two was a
draw and now we are at Game three
so in Game one on fabi's d4 Maxime
replied with that Slav defense that
we've we've enjoyed but here Maxime
decides that it's time to go back to
some playing some normal openings with
black or maybe not so unfocused d4
maxine goes for f5 he goes for the Dutch
defense and okay it does seem that
Maxine came to the tournament to have
some fun we have g3 and now Knight to f6
will rush up to g2 and the g6 now Knight
to f3 we have brush up to g7 and the
Fabi just castles Maxie also castles and
c4 and we have the setup of the
Leningrad
Dutch defense we have b6 by Maxine and
Knight to c3 now we have c6 and now
comes d5 so far we grabs more space in
the center with E 5 by Maxime trying to
get a close center but we have it
captures D captures a nice example song
so we have brush up capture 76 and an
hour b3 preparing to fianchetto the dark
square bishop to oppose blacks dark
square Bishop we have night the a6 by
Maxime and Bishop to b2 Queen e7
developing the Queen connecting rooks
preparing to bring the rook into the
game and III now we ignite the c5 will
be an excellent square for the knight
also you can switch to e4 later on and
Queen e2 Fabi also develops the Queen
connects the rooks and now there is one
game in the database where if I was
played but here rook e8 to d8 is a new
move by Maxime so as of more 13 we have
a completely new game so d5 probably an
idea so rook a to d1 controlling the d5
square and now h6 not allowing any
Knight g5 action and Queen back the c2
now preparing to shift the night over to
e e2 from where it can go to f4 and D
for the ship to f7 opens up the Queen in
the now comes Knight to e2 s plan we
have Knight CT for now and night to d2
now trying to get get
the night from me for a but Maxine goes
back night to see five we have night
back to f3 by Fabi and rook F the e8
with more control of the e4 square we
have night e to d4 and now comes the
night C back to e4 so a lot of horsing
around here we have night back to d2
again offering some trades and now
finally as fabula the magazine goes for
d5 so we have some trades here I see
character C captures and now sorry and
Nazi captors but first blush of
character son b5 and now 92 back to f3
so keeping keeping this cause the the C
pawn nicely guards the bishop here and
it is an excellent outpost for the night
so nice the g4 just getting that night
deeper into the position and here Maxime
has two two excellently placed Knights
and if Bobby wants to kick them away he
will have to further weaken the King
side would h3
we really won by Fabi and now c5 pushing
back the night-nights to b5 with the
idea of shifting it back to c3
if you don't defend a7 that is so Bishop
captures on b2 Queen captures and a6 now
pushing back tonight tonight the c3 and
now just with a double attack on the
night Queen to g7 also the knight cannot
move as the Queen here would Hank okay
you can move it to a foreign d1 but Fabi
goes look the c1 instead defends the c3
Knight and Russia back to c6 also just
opens up the D file for the rook so now
if this Knight moves then ideas like
rook to d2 come to mind
so h3 and here's the moment where Maxime
did take some time to figure out what to
do here as there are really a lot of
moves that come to mind here almost
obvious one of course bringing back the
night but you have to consider knife
captors and g3 have to consider knife
captures and III have to consider knife
captures an f2 and indeed all of the
captors are possible and preferred to
retreating the night but it also
requires time to calculate so Maxime
went back would night to have sex but
Knight captures an f2 would have been
very interesting because you do win the
roof for two nights and after Queen
characters you have this very nice rock
lift with rook to D
three with a double attack on the night
and after the night moves now Queen to
d7 then the other row comes to d8 and
you will have immense pressure along the
D file yes White has two knights for the
rook but your position is is very nice
you are also up upon and the g3 point
seems to be weak so black would
definitely have compensation here but
impossible to deciding in such short
short short time formats
so tonight G to f6 Maxine goes back and
now Fabi trades in the center Knight
captures with Knight captures end Quinta
c2 now we have b5 now preparing rook to
c8 and c4 which will give Maxime a
passed pawn here so rook F to D 1 and
now King to h7 just improving the
position of the king we have night the
d2 now trying to trade everything off
also the the bishops might come off the
board so first look the c8 defending the
bishop and now Fabi traits Knight
characters on e4 with Bishop captures
Bishop captures and rook captures and
here rook to d6 by Fabi are very nice
rook leave going after the a6 pawn and
maxeen instead of trying to trying to
defend the ace exponent which would be
very passive he decides to go for the
active c4 which will give him a pass
pawn so here just rook seated e1
doubling up on the D file and you still
can't capture because the rook would
hang on c8 and the black might have to
worry about some rugged d7 ideas if this
rook ever moves so first look back to e7
and you also have to calculate ideas
like Queen captures rook fall by rook
here if if whitey favors the trade so
just look back to e7 by Maxime but now
rook captures on a6 Fabi grabs a pawn
and rook to d7 now going for the trade
we have rope characters Queen captures
and now a double trade on c4 captures
captures and now Fabi has a passed pawn
on a and the a file and the Maxime has a
fast C pawn but Fabi is still up upon so
rook to a3 not allowing this point to
move further we have rook to c7
in the now rook the c3 we have Queen to
d5 defending and now Fabi starts pushing
his own passport a4 with h5 by Maxine
and now a5 Fabi further starts pushing
the pawn
and here maxime decides that just to
grab it not the defender with Queen b5o
rook to see sexy he decides the trade
and he says that he will hold this three
against four in a queen and pawn endgame
so here we have Queen captures on a five
we have a trade on C four characters
captures and captures and now Queen to a
one wit check we have King to h2 and
Queen back to a seven so it's three
against four Queen Queen opponent game
with pawns on the same side of the board
and usually if you let engines play this
out they will they will well very often
draw the game but for a human it's
surprisingly difficult to for the
defending side to defend and for the
attacking side to convert to the extra
pawn so Queen important I think are the
most difficult of end games so Queen to
f4 Bobby just tries to improve the
position of the Queen we have Queen to
d7 and now Queen to e5 further
centralizing Queen to b7 Maxine just has
to wait and Queen to d6 Fabi just grabs
more space with the Queen Queen to be to
going after the f2 pawn and Queen e7
check now King h6 and King g2 just
defending the f2 point Queen b3 and here
Fabi goes for g4 temporarily giving up a
pawn but he will win it back and he
wants to trade some points and it's a
it's a it's a principle in chess for
example here we have four against three
and now if I be just trades everything
captures captures and captures and now
with check you will pick it up King g7
and now just Queen captures on g4 and
now two against one is a much bigger
advantage than four against four against
three
so Queen d5 check and King g3
we have Queen to c6 and now Queen to d4
with check and now Fabi will slowly but
surely start pushing his his own passed
pawn king h7 and E 4 now we have Queen
to b7 and now II five we have Queen to
b3 check now comes f3 just defending and
Queen to be one now trying to to do some
damage from from behind we have King to
f4 and now Quinta f5 with check King III
Queen to g5 check and now came to d3 so
now what Fabi needs to do is try and
escape all the checks and hopefully
promote one of the pawns
so Queen a5 check we have king a queen
to e4 blocking and now Queenie
I just blocking the spawn and now
looking back to III we have came to g7
and now King to f4 SDF five point F F
square is nicely defended now Queen to
f7 check and King back to g3 now we have
Queen to b3 not allowing f4 and Queen to
d4 now preparing to push the pawn with
check so Quinta east eggs blocking and
Queen to d6 now by white offering a
queen trade so maxime of course the
clients you cannot trade Queens here
Queen to e7 width check now comes King
to g8 and the Queen to d8 with check
that's not a d8 Queen to d8 with check
King to g7 and now point to c7 with
check King g8 and now Queen to c4 with
check again King g7 and the Queen to f4
now trying to trade off the Queen's this
way Queen back to e6 and now Queen to d4
giving black the move so king f7 and now
finally f4 and there is a pawn move so
the 50 room move a 50 move rule goes you
know starts over we have Queen to b3
with check and now King H for Queen b7
we have Queen to d1 now and King to g7
we have Queen to a-1 now again preparing
to push with check and the Queen to e7
check King to g3 and again blocking with
Quinta East six but now Quinta a7 with
check King g8 and the Queen to be a twit
check king of seven and here Queen to c7
with check King g8 and finally Queen to
d6 again the same position we already
had only now the ponies on f4 instead of
an f3 so Queen f5 and now finally six
this is how fab pushes the pawn queen
we have Quinta efore in the now King
back to f2 we have king to g7 in the now
Queen c7 with check King gage 6 and now
Queen to d6 defending the pawn and
trying to put the pond to e7 so we have
King back to g7 and now not going for
not going for East 7 right away because
after king to f7 it would be very hard
to do this since both the Queen and the
king guard the de 8 square so first
Queen to c7 check by fabric English 6
and now e 7 and
that the king is here it is it is easier
now since the King cannot reach f7 in
time 24 check we have King Teti 2 and
now Queen Eve for church so now
Fabi has to figure out how to get rid of
all the checks King D 2 we have Queen D
for check and now King C 2 so you don't
have quincy for check why do you have
Quinta a for but now
Fabi starts to bring in the kingdom of
the board King C 3 Queen a three check
King D four we have Queen to b4 check
King goes to d5 Queen b5 check and now
finally King to b6
we have Quinta d3 with check King to c6
we have Quinta efore with check King d7
Quinta d5 with check and a now finally
Queen to d6 still keeping around both
Mons defending check Queen b7 check and
now finally King to e6
we are Quinta CA to check we have King
to have seven and now Queen to f5 with
check but here Fabi just played Queen to
have sex and it was in this position
that Maxima sherrilyn Grove resigned the
game in game 3 also goes to Fabi which
means as he won two games and one game
was a draw that he wins the match and
Maxime is definitely well definitely out
of the tournament
he will play one more round of course
but he will not go into playoffs as only
the top 4 go into place the playoffs so
here you resigned because after Queen to
d5 check you're gonna go King to f8 and
now there are no more useful checks
anything you do like Queen to a8 which
check will be met with EA Queen and now
it's just game over so a hundred and
three moves is what what it took Fabi to
take down Maxime in this Queen and phone
and game but like I said if Queen
important games are just difficult weird
exhausting and well especially when you
have a little time to calculate every
every Queen move they are pretty much
impossible so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to think a blue
Moxon ROG Carsten Court says Steven
Atkinson Chris Antley and Martin Fisher
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day